him.
[Silence]
Subhan Allah. foreign.
forun.
[Silence]
Subhan Allah.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
and a verse that the prophet sallall.aii
alaihi wasallam recited every night
before he went to bed in Israel
says
look at the people how we have given
some virtue over others.
Some were given wealth over others. Some
were given knowledge over others,
strength over others, skills,
intelligence, understanding.
Some have a head start as they say in
life, others not so much. And this is
all for the purpose of testing humanity,
to test all of us with that which we
have been given.
and to spread the gifts out that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala has given us all.
He says in surah yuf and above each
person of knowledge
is one more knowledgeable
and this goes across the board with all
of the gifts of Allah.
Any person of intelligence
know that somewhere out there there is
someone more intelligent, more smart,
more dedicated, stronger,
richer,
more determined,
healthier,
more beautiful,
more handsome,
etc.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala spread his
gifts out.
And so a person is never to imagine
that he is at the top
and the ultimate of anything that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala has given him
because above each one of us and above
each of our gifts there's someone out
there whom Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala has
given this gift to and perhaps more
plentifully And this is to teach us
humility
abdahb
the prophet sallall.aii wasallam's
cousin
and the most knowledgeable
of his companions with respect to the
meanings of the Quran.
He narrates that the messenger of Allah
sallall.aii Wasam
once told the companions
that Musam
was asked by some of his followers
who is the most knowledgeable person on
earth. Now this question
is largely
is largely unnecessary.
This question is similar to the
questions that Benny is would constantly
ask because they viewed their messenger
as more of an entertainer
than they viewed him as someone who has
brought them guidance.
And so anything that would pop into
their head, they would ask. the most
silliest of things they would ask and
the most silliest of things they would
sometimes say. And Allah Subhanahu Wa
Ta'ala teaches us to learn from that
mistake.
The prophet sallall.aii Wasam says,
"That which has destroyed the previous
nations before you is their constant
questioning
and
their disobedience to their prophets and
messengers.
After all this questions, questions
about the most finest of details,
their actions are very
or their actions are very lacking
with respect to the implementation of
that knowledge that they asked for in
the first place.
And so Misam
responded
with that which he knew at the time.
I said of course I am. He is the
messenger of Allah. He is the one who
speaks directly to Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala.
And so Allah subhanahu waala
taught him and taught
and taught us
that
that above every person of knowledge
there is someone out there who
possesses that which is above it. The
gifts of Allah are spread out. They are
dispersed. No one person has all of
them.
And so Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
instructed Mosa to go to a particular
place to travel to it and to take a fish
with him, a dead fish,
and to watch this fish and to go to this
particular place and to travel far out
of his way. Because when he arrives at
this particular place at this particular
time,
there is a man there whom we have given
to knowledge that we have not even given
to you.
And so Misam
eager to learn. This is not a
punishment. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala is
not punishing MS by teaching him. Rather
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
wishes for him to learn more and beyond
even that which he was given. And so he
took one of his closest servants.
And I needed to be present for this as
well because he was appointed a prophet
for Bi is after the passing of MS and
Harimatam.
And so they took this fish with them and
they set out
and they traveled and they traveled
and they passed the place where they
were supposed to meet.
When they set up camp there,
the fish
came to life
and they were on a beach and it left in
the ocean
or in the sea.
And I observed this. He was going to
tell Musam this incredible thing that
this fish came back to life. We've been
carrying it for days and it's dead
clearly and it woke up and flapped
itself into the water and took off. But
he forgot it slipped his mind. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala attributes this to a
shan
because when a person seeks out to learn
from Allah, a shan will try his best
to throw a wrench into his gears to
stop him on his path and hinder him as
best as he can because knowledge is the
death of El's trick.
And so he made him to forget. How could
you forget such a thing?
[Silence]
Allah Subhanahu
WAS
[Silence]
And so
he they passed the point where they were
supposed to be. They kept traveling but
they started to feel very exhausted.
[Silence]
and so
Misam
said to you on their travels, "Prepare
our lunch. We are very exhausted from
our constant traveling. And this is what
sparked his memory. He said
the fish that we had, it actually did
wake up. It actually did take off in the
sea and I forgot to tell you and a shan
made me to forget. And so he said to
him, "That is what we've been waiting
for. That's the sign. Do you remember
where it was that it woke up? He said,
"Yes." And so they returned to that
place.
And when they returned to that place,
and Allah Subhanahu Wa'ta'ala describes
it as
Majim,
a place where two seas or two great
bodies of water meet. And the scholars
differ on exactly where this place is.
It's inconsequential.
What's important is that they came back
and they found who they were looking for
there.
The prophet sallall.aii wasallam
identified this man as
it is correct to say
or
two pronunciations of the same name.
They came back and they found al there.
Now al
is a messenger of Allah
and we know that he is a prophet.
Why do we know that he is a prophet?
Well, first of all, he receives
revelation from Allah.
He receives revelation
and even knowledge of the future that
even Musam is not privy to.
Doesn't mean he can see everything in
the future all the time. No, it is only
particular things that Allah subhanahu
[Arabic recitation]
reveals to him and sends revelation
informing him of things to come, things
of the unseen, of the knowledge of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
But here's really why the scholars tell
us that Al is a prophet.
Because even if a person has knowledge,
that is only one part of the equation.
As we'll see, he has knowledge and he
has authority and permission from Allah
to act upon that knowledge.
He destroys the property, property
that's not his. He takes the life of a
child.
Even if he were to know what was going
to happen, even if Musam himself was
privy to this knowledge, the law of
Allah prohibits him from acting upon
this knowledge. You cannot destroy the
property of other people without their
permission. You cannot take a life
without permission from Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala and authority. But alabul has
this authority
and so
Mam meets Al and Allah describes Al with
a very interesting description.
He says, "Subhan,
[Silence]
forch.
for
[Silence]
you
whom
And
It's not yet.
for
[Silence]
And so traditionally the scholars of
hadith the first
narration that they would narrate to
their students
is the statement of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam.
The merciful
will be shown mercy by Alman the
ultimate and vastly merciful.
Have mercy on those who are upon the
earth and the one who is above will have
mercy upon you. This is the first
narration they would narrate to their
students. Why? Because this knowledge of
the Quran and Sunnah is all built and
based and founded on a foundation of
mercy. And so Allah he described.
He said that
he is a an individual whom Allah gave
mercy to.
He was a merciful person. Allah taught
him mercy and then he taught him more
knowledge.
And so this knowledge is built and based
on mercy. And this is why Allah tells us
about the messenger Muhammad's message.
He says to the prophet sallall.aii
wasallam in the closing verses of surah
and we have not sent you oh Muhammad
except as a mercy for all of mankind or
for all of the worlds.
And so this message is a message of
mercy. This is why the first thing Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
made it that the listener or the reader
of his book first hears is a message of
mercy.
That's the first thing the first
statement in the book of Allah because
this knowledge is built and based on
mercy. It was not sent to curse people.
It was not sent to damn people. It was
sent as a mercy. And what is mercy?
What's the interpretation of that? Mercy
is not just a feeling that you have.
It's not just something that you feel
overly zealous about. Mercy
is always one of two things. Either
justice or excellence.
Any person that deals with you, anyone
who brushes shoulders with the religion
of Allah must experience at least
justice and at best
excellence and
never anything outside of those two.
[Silence]
[Arabic recitation]
Take a moment to observe your place in
the row. Align your shoulders with the
shoulders of your two neighbors on
either side of you. Align your feet and
your ankles with the feet and ankles of
the people on your two neighbors on
either side of you. They don't have to
be touching but they have to be in line.
This is how the companions would
straighten their rows. The prophet
sallall.aii alaihi wasallam emphasized
straightening straightening our rows and
warns us
that you will straighten your rose in
prayer or Allah will cause disharmony
amongst your hearts.
Please double check your phone. Ensure
that it is silent.
Know that one day you will come and this
will be your last prayer.
So you don't know when that will be.
Make every prayer your last prayer.
Alhamdulillah.
for
[Arabic recitation]
Dear brothers and sisters, asalam
alaikum.
Couple of quick announcements. First,
the fud kama starting tomorrow morning
will be at 4:45
a.m. Again, fudama inshallah at 4:45
a.m. We have the youth evening tonight
and there are the the we are requesting
that please bring the your youngsters
with you inshallah to benefit from the
hadith lecture inshallah from sheh Ali.
Also, I'd to make a request.
The some of the air conditioning has
been running 24/7 in the masjid or in in
the masid buildings. So, please help us.
We are going to put the locks on the
gymnasium air conditioning and if you
when you reserve it, they will be
unlocked or you'll be provided the key
for that. If you see air conditioning
running and nobody's using it or people
are leaving, just make sure you take
stop by and just, you know, adjust or at
least shut off the air conditioning if
you can, inshallah. We don't want
everybody to manage the ACs. However, we
need to shut down the wasteful
electricity that we are that we are
doing abundance at this point. So,
please donate generously on the way out.
Slowly.